hola bienvenidos de nuevo bueno ahora
haré un repaso de todo lo que hemos
estado haciendo hasta el momento sobre
trigonometría identidades
trigonométricas y después veremos si
podemos usar lo que ya sabemos para
obtener nuevas identidades
trigonométricas entonces de soca tohá
sabemos que el seno de teta
es igual a cateto opuesto propuesto
sobre hipotenusa y aquí voy a dibujar un
triángulo rectángulo entonces
más o menos ok ese es un truco
rectángulo supongamos aquí está teta y
aquí tenemos el que aceptó opuesto el
adyacente y la hipotenusa y bueno seno
de teta es opuesto sobre hipotenusa
coseno de teta es igual a adyacente
sobre hipotenusa y la tangente de teta
es igual a cateto puesto sobre cateto
adyacente lo cual también es lo mismo
que seno de teta sobre coseno de teta y
bueno aquí tienes tu identidades que son
por definición son fáciles de memorizar
porque bueno ya te enseño también el
sujeto a eso te ayuda bastante pero por
ejemplo la cose calde teta la co secante
de teta esto es igual a la hipotenusa
sobre cateto puesto lo cual es lo mismo
esto es igual a 1 sobre seno de teta y
solo identidades que deben memorizar son
básicas como te digo el soca tohá ayuda
bastante y ahora vamos con la sec ante
la sec ante de teta son términos que tú
debes usar por se usan por convención y
si llegas al término de uno
kosen o simplemente dice sólo es esa
secante de teta de chubut que tiene
algunas propiedades que tú podrías ver
analizar si dibujes el círculo unitario
pero en fin en la secante de teta es
igual a la hipotenusa sobre cateto
adyacente lo cual es igual a 1 sobre
coseno de teta y ahora vamos con la cota
en gente de teta esto es igual a cateto
adyacente sobre cateto opuesto lo cual
es igual a 1 sobre tangente de teta lo
cual también es igual a esto es sacar o
pongo abajo es igual al coseno de teta
sobre seno de teta simplemente es la
inversa de tangente y también importante
estas son identidades que tú obtienes
como te digo de las otras son casi por
definición no te olvides eso kato al
sujeto es muy importante su seno opuesto
sobre pot en usa k coseno adyacente
sobre pod en usa sitúa tangente opuesto
sobre adyacente ajá así que bueno aquí
lo más sencillo porque no me acuerdo
ahorita que esto es igual pero lo
podemos probar
el chiste es aquí jugar con esto así que
esto es igual a 1 sobre la secante de
teta
secante de teta y todo esto sobre 1
sobre josé khan tdt está con secante de
teta y luego bueno esto es igual a que
es igual a la secante perdón a la
constante esto es igual a la co secante
sobre el haz y cante ahora sabemos que
la cotrán gente de teta es igual a 1
sobre tangente de teta lo cual es igual
a cossec andrade trata sobre seno de
teta lo cual también es igual a la co
secante sobre la secante y en realidad
no es no no deben memorizar estas como
te das cuenta y tampoco las tenía
memorizadas porque lo que me gusta de
esto es que siempre puedes llegar a
otras identidades jugando con las
identidades que ya conoces ahora también
tenemos el seno cuadrado de teta más
cose no cuadra de teta
esto es igual a 1 eso sale del teorema
de pitágoras y si juegas un poco con
esto también obtiene es que la tangente
cuadrada de teta más 1 eso es igual a la
secante cuadrado de teta y como es que
llego yo de esta ecuación a esta otra a
bueno pues dividiendo la primera
actuación por seno cuadrado de teta y
ahora también si ya viste los dos vídeos
pasados fueron fueron de dos pruebas el
coste no deja más ve y el seno de hamás
ve ahora de eso sabemos que el seno de
amd
es igual eso es igual al seno de a
seno de a el seno de a x el coche no
debe
jose no debe más y aquí ya no tengo
espacio así que voy a borrar no son
cosas que no tiene mucha importancia
esto que voy a borrar ahorita porque tú
lo puedes obtener ya viste más o menos
como le hice simplemente es jugando con
las identidades y obtienes cosas nuevas
es lo es lo divertido de la
trigonometría y ahora muy bien ya tengo
espacio así que esto es más más el el
seno de a por el seno de b más el seno
de b por el coseno de a
coseno de a y tal vez te topes con esta
de hecho me morí sala porque tal vez de
la topes en cálculo cuando hagas una
derivada una integral muy probable que
esto salga así que esta sí es muy
importante memorizar la porque como
puedes ver es el seno de un ángulo por
el coste no del otro ángulo más el co
seno de un ángulo por el seno del otro
ángulo y también aprendimos que el coste
no de a más de esto es lo mismo es igual
al coste no de ambos ángulos así que lo
pongo aquí el coseno de a por el coste
no debe
coseno de becerro paréntesis ahí está
- menos esto ya lo probé en otro vídeo
el seno de a x el seno de b y ahí lo
tienes el coste no deja más ve estas son
muy importantes porque de éstas salen
muchas otras identidades por ejemplo
cuál es el aquí perfecto
cuál es el seno el seno de 2 a eso es lo
mismo que el seno de a más acierto esto
es igual a seno de a más
porque bueno si usamos esta identidad de
cada arriba eso es igual al seno de an
por el coseno de amd el seno de a por el
coste no de a más
más el seno de a por el coche no de a
simplemente es esta identidad de acá
arriba de seno de a ver dónde hay ves
son ambos
o sea es igual a b en este caso y esto a
que es igual son el mismo término cierto
así que esto es igual a dos seno de a
por co seno de a ésta también es muy
importante tal vez de la tele encuentres
en tu tarea o o en algún libro así que
es muy buena tenerla a la mano y bueno
vamos a hacer otra aún de hecho una vez
que ya tengas tu buen repertorio de
identidades trigonométricas tal vez
juegas con ellas y así llegas a más y
más identidades trigonométricas cada vez
más hasta llegar a infinito es que es
muy divertido de hecho has lo
juega con estas identidades es bastante
divertido ahora por ejemplo hagamos
hagamos el coseno de 2 a coseno de 2 a
esto es igual al coste no de a más
acierto y ok
sí bueno coste no de amasar que dijimos
que era eso es igual
es igual al coseno de ambos ángulos
multiplicados así que es el coseno de a
por el coste no deal
esto - el seno de ambos ángulos
multiplicados así que el seno de a por
el seno de a y bueno ya tenemos aquí la
identidad para el coste no deja más ve
pero pero aquí ve es igual a a y bueno
que qué es esto estos igual esto es
igual al coste no cuadrado de a menos el
seno cuadrado de a y esto es muy
interesante porque como tú puedes
observar podríamos jugar con esto porque
porque esto tiene la forma de coseno
cuadrado de a menos en el cuadrado deja
entonces a mars b por a menos b lo bueno
tiene esa forma lo voy a escribir acá
abajo esto es lo mismo que josé no de a
más seno de ha multiplicado todo esto
multiplicado por el coseno de a menos el
seno de a esto no es una identidad sólo
te quiero mostrar que tú puedes jugar un
rato aquí para ver que para ver qué sale
curiosidad vaya entonces bueno coseno de
a es igual a coseno de seno de a todo
esto multiplicado por el coste no de a
menos el seno de an
en fin a mí me parece muy interesante
esto ahora es divertido puedes jugar con
ellas como te digo y encontrar nuevas
identidades trigonométricas de hecho yo
imagino que así fue como las las
hallaron todas así que digamos que
queremos que queremos averiguar cuál es
el coste no de menos
entonces voy a dibujar una de un
triángulo rectángulo a más o menos ahí
está el triángulo rectángulo supongamos
que es un triángulo rectángulo y digamos
que este es el ángulo am y acá está en
el círculo unitario el ángulo menos
ahora coseno de a si este es el lado
adyacente esta es el lado adyacente aquí
está la hipotenusa también esto sería la
hipotenusa aquí está el cateto opuesto y
también este es el menos cateto opuesto
por lo tanto el coste no de menos an es
igual a qué cosa es adyacente sobre
hipotenusa pero eso lo mismo que coseno
de a
adyacentes sobre el pod en usa es igual
al coseno de an porque coseno de a
también es adyacente sobre hipotenusa
entonces ya ya casi no tengo tiempo ok
lo sigo en el próximo vídeo bueno nos
vemos